e che ne dici del messaggio secondo cui
dovremmo ricercare la verità ci fa
dimenticare che una vita senza mistero e
arida e che certe cose per esempio i
nostri amici andrebbero più amati che
capiti fino in fondo
forse era ben chiaro sul metodo
il grande allievo delle piste nologo più
importanti del novecento cartwright
popper
ma non solo tutte le cose sono unite da
legami invisibili non puoi cogliere un
fiore senza turbare una stella 1564 1642
galileo galilei
ecco questo è il tema che vi voglio
proporre cioè il neuro cuore il fatto
che tutto ciò che l'uomo fa è amore
tutto ciò che avviene nel nostro
cervello e solidarietà
non c'è un neurone che lavori da solo
siamo noi nella società che dividiamo ma
tutto ciò che ha natura il sistema tutto
ciò che è in mano al sistema
tutto ciò che è rivoluzione e sistema
noi stiamo vivendo un periodo molto
importante che ciò che michael tomasello
che il vicedirettore del market
institute di lipsia uno psicologo
culturale in nei suoi testi che sono
indicati dal mulino bologna dice siamo
in cultural drive
cioè siamo di fronte a una spinta
culturale una spinta culturale e quando
il nome di una teoria particolarmente
interessante dell'evoluzione dell'essere
umano che la teoria degli equilibri
punteggiati proposta nel 1972 e
l'evoluzione non avviene in maniera
lineare ma viene attraverso una serie
come dire di significati
spinte che avvengono nel mondo e che
danno come dire un senso ed hanno anche
una direzione poi accade che non tutti
ascoltino queste direzioni e non tutti
abbiano il coraggio di attuare ma
coraggio cosa vuol dire coraggio deriva
dal latino cor cordis che ha coraggio a
cuore il coraggio non è la forza il
coraggio e la potenza della maternità
il coraggio e la potenza della
generatività è la la voglia di generare
di generare che cosa simboli significati
e carla raimond popper ci ricorda sempre
che un grande politico lo si riconosce
dalla capacità di avere senso dopo la
sua morte come ci ricorda sempre lui che
una buona scuola la si riconosce nella
capacità di gettare i cattivi maestri
allora adesso vi racconto che cosa sono
gli aspetti filogenetici cioè della
nostra evoluzione che sogni che
significano il contatto
partiamo da questo presupposto ognuno di
noi credenti avere una propria identità
e crediamo di essere quello che spesso
diciamo di essere è anche vero che molto
spesso quando qualcuno ci dice chi sei
diciamo quello che facciamo è difficile
che un adulto di fronte alla domanda chi
sei
risponda sono felice e sono realizzato
sono appassionato sono un poeta ci
dicono quello che fanno non ci dicono
con gesù un lavoro però from ci ricorda
che avere essere sono delle cose diverse
ma anche dal punto di vista
antropologico l'avere essere sono due
cose diverse
allora noi nasciamo col gesto perché
tutto è gesto sto parlando gesto fa un
articolato orio gestito dall aria di
spero sinistra collegato con la
fascicolo arcuato nell'aria diverbi che
di vernice la giusta pronuncia che ha il
significato ad esempio come avviene il
significato di un concetto di una parola
mamma se la mamma quando dice giovanni
vieni sono la tua mano alla carezza la
mente teoria della mente incarnata
capisce che il gesto di quel suono
significa la parola ti voglio bene se
quando una mamma chiama forse quando noi
parliamo dei nostri studenti
facciamo dei gesti esprimiamo dei come
dire e i comportamenti che il
significano io sono e tu non sei non
passa di formazione quindi il gesto è
fondamentale questo è uno dei gesti che
ci è mancato e che dovremmo recuperare
c'è una zona del nostro cervello che si
chiama compenso nucleo a con dente che
ha una funzione importante insieme alla
vendita da di gestire l'istinto di
sopravvivenza quello che si chiama la
pulsione sopravvivenza da con pensa si
attiva quando io stringo la mano a una
persona e manda una serie di
informazione alla corteccia frontale
prefrontale dicendoli fidati di questa
persona
noi dobbiamo avere la volontà di criteri
negli altri siamo in un momento storico
in cui ci viene chiesto questo dal
sistema ci viene chiesto dal sistema
natura dobbiamo voli
nella l'importanza della diversità e nel
mio testo ha scritto questo pianeta
si intitola questo testo diversamente
uguali
dobbiamo imparare che la globalizzazione
ci sta dicendo la natura ci sta dicendo
siamo diversamente uguali e questa
dimensione è la dimensione che è molto
cara all'evoluzione perché chi non si
adatterà a questa dimensione non solo
continuerà ad alzare muri non solo
continuerà a credere di avere
un'identità precisa ma nello stesso
tempo crederà che la sua identità sia
l'esempio di tutte le altre identità
un concetto importante della materia che
porta avanti io porto avanti in
antropologia della mente vi faccio
ridere sono il migliore perché sono
l'unico
e così arriviamo un po ma ci sto diventa
una cosa un po troppo seria quello che
si dice essere però è molto importante
sapere anche che la serietà e fatta di
ironia e l'antropologia della mente io
sono l'unico allievo del professor
gallino museo di firenze con i quadri
non mi sono laureato e che ha fondato
negli anni 80 la antropologia cognitiva
cioè come l'est e romano conosce il
mondo
io sono andato avanti mettendo insieme
gli studi neuroscienze con la teoria
darwinista dell'evoluzione e quindi
studio come si è evoluta la mente cos'è
la mente chiariamolo e ciò del cervello
fa con se stesso e con gli altri
partendo da questo presupposto che ha a
che fare con la teoria della mente
incarnata cioè il significato si incarna
nella limitazione per esempio è il mira
un i rom scoperti da giacomo rizzolatti
neurofisiologo dell'università di parma
hanno dimostrato il ruolo della
imitazione ecco limitazione è
fondamentale per capire che ad esempio
noi non siamo quello che crediamo di
essere noi siamo quello che diventeremo
quando voi sentite che le persone
rimangono
deluse perché cambiano e credevo che
fosse così invece non è così mi sono
fidato di questa persona e poi invece mi
ha fregato
no si è rivelato la rivelazione e
dinamica io sono quello che diventerò
noi non siamo qui per quello che
crediamo di essere noi siamo qui perché
siamo tutti insieme per scoprire cosa
potremmo diventare insieme l'identità si
forma solo nella relazione nove mesi
dentro la pancia la nostra madre in cui
beta endorfine endorfine il suono del
cuore tanta tanta tanta a tre quarti
tutte le milan anni sono in sei ottavi
in tre parti di fronte al valzer nessuno
non può che essere sereno e tranquillo
perché sono nove mesi di vana ci sono
nove mesi di benessere si chiama
saturazione affettiva all'interno di
quell'ambiente che si chiama minute roma
nasce la vita chi desidera una sola cosa
avere un utero esterno qual è il motore
sterno la società fino a quando non
capiremo questo a livello evolutivo non
selezioneremo questo e noi saremo un pò
indietro quindi tutto el'attività
motoria
sto tornando indietro perché è che cosa
è accaduto e ha capito che prima eravamo
in un ambiente arboricolo quindi
vivevamo di notte no eravamo vicino alle
scimmie
antropomorfi nostri che sono gli
scimpanzé con i quali condividiamo il 97
per cento dei geni e il 57 per cento dei
geni lo condividiamo con la tortuoso
fila melanogaster il moscerino della
frutta e gli ultimissimi studi ci dicono
che circa il 73 per cento dei geni lo
condividiamo con i cani è per questo che
noi stiamo molto bene con gli animali e
con i cani
allora poi andiamo in un ambiente
terricolo e quindi nel momento in cui
andiamo in una mente pericolo scopriamo
il corpo perché faccio così riguardo
attenzione non mi guardo mai
attentamente voi fino a quando non
arriva l'estate
avete mai pensato al vostro calcagno
ritoccate cosi il polpaccio alla mattina
ppv stoccati il gomito per sapere come
sta
non siamo coscienti della parte che non
vediamo del nostro corpo non badiamo
alla schiena ea maltrattiamo ma quando
dobbiamo spogliarci dobbiamo essere
uguale a tutti gli altri nella nostra
nudità allora ci rendiamo conto che il
polpaccio funziona che lo devo curare se
non ho un dolore alla cervicale non mi
rendo conto dell'importanza del collo
perché l'essere umano è legato a questo
sistema telemetrico che è la vista che
ha fatto grandi cose ma ha eliminato
altre cose quindi abbiamo gli arti
superiori e gli arti inferiori quando
assumiamo la posizione eretta
abbiamo le mani ma cosa me ne faccio di
queste mani allora innanzitutto comincio
a capire che il pollice si oppone e
posso prendere delle cose questa è una
scoperta spaventosa ma non solo inizio a
contare al sistema 12.23 45
7 8 9 10 11 12 non è di 10 il sistema
giusto e li 12 perché contiamo in questo
modo e ci sono dei reperti
interessantissima che risalgono a 40
mila tifa che proprio raccontano come
l'uomo altro piteco ma non solo anche
proprio solo e sanchez
comincia a contare in questo modo gli
arti inferiori ovviamente ci servono a
muoverci muoverci una cosa importante
non esiste progetto se non c'è il
movimento del corpo
chiariamo subito che in tutti i manuali
neuroscienze oggi non si parla più di
mente corpo contrattino e mente corpo
tutto attaccato in corsivo perché il
corpo e non rovescio veramente avete
presente una coperta
voi vedete la parte esterna che quello
che noi siamo il nostro corpo la mente e
la rovescio di questa coperta allora non
può esserci una sanità del corpo se non
c'è una sanità della mente il pollice
opponibile la deambulazione bp de mi
permette di fare una cosa progettare a
gino però gettare gettare in avanti
importantissimo ricordarci l'etimologia
gli usa fa grande riferimento ma anche
michelle fu comunque un archeologia del
sapere ma young e ci ricorda
profondamente quel significato
archetipico delle parole
provate a pensare a detenuti una specie
poi che parlerà e è in stato
interessante
cosa vuol dire essere in stato
interessante interesse una donna incinta
è tra l'essenza della vita la sua e
quella che sta crescendo
guardate la poesia che c'è dietro questo
non conosciamo ma è la nostra altezza
fino a quando non siamo chiamati ad
alzarci e se siamo fedeli al nostro
compito ha rivali cerio la nostra
statura l'eroismo che allora recitiamo
sarebbe quotidiano
se noi stessi non ci curva assimo di
cubiti per la paura
ad essere dei re elli dickinson 1863 la
vista e l'udito ci permettono quindi di
progettare ci permettono quindi di
sentire e ci permettono più in 20
migliorare la nostra percezione di che
cosa del futuro il futuro c'è quando le
persone si possono muovere cosa ha
creato il look town l'assenza del
contatto col futuro ha creato
esattamente questo perché non poterci
muovere non permette alla nostra vita di
sapere che se io ho un luogo dove posso
credere e posso pensare di trovare la
mia evoluzione
il mio dinamismo non ci posso andare
allora abbiamo sostituito con una
rappresentazione olografica delle
persone che internet grandissima cosa
idevices
la tecnologia grandiosa cosa ma
attenzione se rimaniamo australopitechi
con il computer scesi dall albero la
tecnologia non fa niente
la tecnologia non potrà sostituire non
potrà mai esserci intelligenza
artificiale che abbia la coscienza e le
emozioni ci potranno essere dei
logaritmi potranno esserci dei motori
neurali come si usa dire ma la cosa
bella
l'emozione che stiamo provando qui e qui
dentro il cervello più grande del cielo
perché mette di fianco a fianco
lui non altro
con facilità e tu in aggiunta il
settembre più profondo del mare perché
chiedilo azzurro contro l'azzurro l'uno
l'altro servirà come le spugne di
secchia assorbono il cervello ha giusto
il peso di dio perché soppesa letto
peretto ed essi differiranno si
riferiranno come la silla nadal sono
sempre lei emily dickinson 1864 rilegata
vent'anni con un abito bianco da sola
nel massachusetts padri padroni con un
amore che non è mai riuscita a esprimere
è importante che cos'è questa donna il
futuro della specie femminile ci può
trust non salvare solo la il modo di
accogliere la giustificazione del
femminile il maschile ha fallito e molte
cose riuscito nella conquista dei
terreni tanto è vero che abbiamo 8 per
cento giu di neuroni come maschi secondo
le ricerche di van riemsdyk nel suo
testo il cervello di maschi e poi ha
scritto che diceva delle masche del 2010
2007 scrive il cervello delle donne
racconta ad esempio che noi abbiamo un 8
per cento in più di neuroni per la
gestione dello spazio ma le femmine
umane hanno l'undici per cento in più
nella gestione del linguaggio perché la
femmina umana ipoteca al futuro con la
parola e sensibilissima la parola del
figlio e sensibilissimo la parola degli
altri perché quando uno se meno umana
dice stai attento che con le forbici ti
fai male rende autonomo suo figlio
quando lei morirà capite che cosa in
quanto è importante l'educazione da 0 a
3 anni collegamenti neuronali al 50 per
cento sono fanti 12 34 c
contiamo così e contiamo quanti
collegamenti neuronali con questo ritmo
25 milioni di anni impiegheremo a
contare con questo ritmo
i nostri collegamenti neuronali beato
colui che grava sulla vita e senza
sforza intende linguaggio dei fiori ed
ogni altra cosa brutta
ciao modeler questo famoso dei fiori del
male
il mistero è dentro di noi
eccoli qui di sviluppo della vita di
relazione il contratto il contratto
formale il contatto informale sono cosa
abbastanza facili i grumi è una cosa
molto bella e quando le scimmie
antropomorfe in una situazione di e
gerarchia si spulcia dei pidocchi ed è
perché è importante perché quello che
esattamente noi facciamo con il nostro
amore o la nostra amata quando li
togliamo i puntini nel naso è
esattamente quando noi pettiniamo la
persona che vogliamo bene un quando c'è
un genitore che ci lava lo deve fare
della dimensione la persona
gerarchicamente più importante cioè una
persona che si prende cura della
debolezza e della fragilità
c'è una persona che deve diventare più
adulta
allora cos'è la vita quotidiana credenza
la credenza un atto di fiducia
intelletto da intus legere aver letto
quindi vuol dire semplicemente poter
leggere oltre l'apparenza delle cose la
persona intelligente non è
necessariamente la persona alfabetizzata
peraltro come dice il grande filosofo
carlo sini università di milano
noi siamo sotto la tirannia
dell'alfabeto come se tutto quello che
vale dovesse essere iscritto dovesse
essere raccontato con la parola in
realtà la comunicazione umana è nata con
il segno rupestre con il suono che poi
diventano
musica il famoso gesto il suono e parola
la nostra capacità di comunicazione e
comunicare vuol dire mettere in comune
il latino
ecco la nostra capacità di comunicazione
nasce se siamo educati i bambini da 4
mesi sviluppa con impatti anzi quattro
mesi dopo esser nati e se non vengono
fatti dei giochi attraverso cui il
bambino si mette nei panni dell'altro il
bambino crede di essere solo un crede di
avere sempre ragione
ecco le persone che credono di avere
sempre ragione sono uno stato di
deficienza relativamente alta desiderio
tesi dai bus il desiderio essere lontano
dalle stelle perché desideri dorso conti
li intorno alle stelle ma guardando le
ecco perché i grandi filosofi sono
pastori per che camminano del deserto e
si chiedono ma dove vanno
dove andiamo tutti e guardano le stelle
perché tutto ciò che essa ancora è
separato da noi di sacco e non è vicino
il sacro vuol dire lontano perché un
figlio è sacro sembri per un genitori
perché in questa lontananza c'è il
meglio di questo genitore pur facendo
gli errori normali ma i genitori cosa fa
rende sacro e proprio fare sacrificare
rendere il sacro il fare e il sacro e
immutabile e genitore non esistono due
avverbi che noi possiamo usare se non
siamo i genitori mai è sempre per un
genitore figlio è sempre e mai non sarà
finché questi sotto di c2 avverbi che la
natura ci dà nella genera attività e
sono validi l'immaginazione
se non immaginiamo non saremmo qui il
timore non essere così con
che tutto sia sulle nostre sulle nostre
capacità
perciò considerando il giorno estremo
nessun mortale dobbiamo stimare felice
a meno che abbia oltrepassato il termine
della sua vita senza aver sofferto paio
alcun dolore e tipo ii sofocle tutti
sono doloranti il dolore è quella quota
necessaria di differenza fra mille
stelle e quella quota necessaria che vi
permette di muovermi
insomma avrei tante cose da dirvi mi
sembra di essere alla fine
viviamo quindi per imparare
epistemologia i loro già mistica questo
è il mio concetto di contatto
willie green card raimondo po per goran
lorenzo il futuro è aperto siamo nel
1940 e viene poi ripresa nel 1960 noi
viviamo tanto perché savinetti siamo in
fattori
abbiamo bisogno di tanto tempo e di
frequentare con una certa assiduità e
costanza il nostro futuro
lo facciamo attraverso confusioni
attraverso la speranza io definisco la
speranza l'esercizio quotidiano della
volontà e abbiamo notato che questo
esercizio quotidiano nella volontà rende
tutti in grado di raggiungere il proprio
successo e ci sono gli studi di madrid
cisco roma che ha pubblicato bellissimo
testo per ogni editore in roma intorno
al 2005 intitolato i sette capitali e
sette peccati capitali del cervello lei
e neuropsicologa dell'università di
tilburg si legge benissimo una grande e
divulgatrice e che consiglio a tutti
di cosa siamo padroni di atteggiamento e
volontà l'atteggiamento e la fase
iniziale di un atto senza atteggiamento
non c'è volontà sono reciprocamente
veicolanti su questi due elementi
gestiti un po dal sistema limbico
l'atteggiamento in alcuni aspetti e poi
dalla corteccia frontale per affrontare
la corteccia prefrontale prefrontali è
quello più importante è quella che fa
parte della neo cortex vi ricordo che
all 85 per cento del funzionamento
cerebrale è pura emozione il 15 per
cento e quella cosa che mi chinavo
razionalità e la corteccia cerebrale è
spessa 6 mm bene io finirei così la vita
non è uno scherzo prendila sul serio
come fa ad esempio lo scoiattolo senza
aspettarsi nulla dall'esterno
al di là non avrai altro da fare che
vivere la vita non è uno scherzo
prendila sul serio come fa ad esempio un
uomo con le banche legate o un
ricercatore con grandi occhiali in
camice bianco che nel suo laboratorio
viva e riconosca l'uomo amandolo per
quello che la vita non è uno scherzo
prendila sul serio o sul serio a tal
punto che a 70 anni ad esempio canterai
degli ulivi
non perché restino ai tuoi figli ma
perché non crederai alla morte importi
mendola e la vita misera di più sulla
bilancia masima
hickman grazie